Identify the hypothesis and
conclusion of the following
statement, and determine whether
the statement is
always, sometimes,
or never true.
So let's see what the
statement is.
We have x-- well, this should be
an x squared plus 5x plus 7
is greater than 0 for
all real numbers x.
So first let's rewrite this
as a proposition,
as an if/then statement.
Then it becomes a lot easier to
identify the hypothesis and
the conclusion.
So we could rewrite this as
if x is a real number,
then this is true.
Then, x squared plus 5x plus
7 is greater than 0.
And when you write it as an
if/then statement like this,
it becomes a lot easier to
identify the hypothesis and
the conclusion.
Now the hypothesis is literally
just what the if
part is conjuring up.
So this right here in pink.
x is a real number.
That's the hypothesis.
Sometimes it's called
the antecedent.
That is the hypothesis.
And as we said in previous
videos, it's different,
although related, to the
notion of a scientific
hypothesis.
Here we're dealing with the
hypothesis of a hypothetical
proposition.
Don't want to confuse
you too much.
It's what's inside of the if
part of the statement.
The conclusion is the conclusion
from the then, or
it's the consequent
right here.
Then that.
That right there is
the conclusion.
We could have labeled
this too.
The conclusion here is this
statement right here.
That right there is
the conclusion.
That is what you conclude
if x is a real number.
So you could say for all that is
the hypothesis right there.
For all real numbers x, that
is the hypothesis.
Either way you want to do it,
it's always easier to write it
as an if/then statement.
Now, the more interesting
question is whether this
statement is always, sometimes,
or never true.
And the first thing that might
pop out at you is that the
coefficient on the highest
degree term here, on the x
squared term, it's a positive
coefficient.
So this is going to be an
upward opening parabola.
Let me draw that.
So if this is the x-axis,
whether this is always,
sometimes, or never true rests
on whether the vertex, whether
the minimum point of this
parabola is above
or below the x-axis.
Let me draw it for you.
So if the parabola looks like
this, then for any x you pick,
the value of the function, the
value of x squared plus 5x
plus 7 is always going
to be greater than 0.
If the function looks like this,
then you're going to
have some values for x where
it's greater than 0.
But you're going to have some
values for x where it is equal
or less than 0.
So we have to determine whether
it sits above or maybe
on or below, the x-axis.
And that's the y-value
of the vertex.
Now we know that it's
not never true.
We know that it's not never true
because this is an upward
opening parabola.
Even if your vertex is a
negative number, eventually,
if you get far enough away from
it, you're going to get
the positive values
of this function.
So we know it's not never true,
we just have to decide
between always and sometimes.
And to figure that out, let's
figure out where the vertex--
and in particular, where the
y-value of the vertex is.
But in order to get that
y-value, you need the x value.
So the x-value of the vertex,
there's a formula here.
I normally don't like giving
formulas, but we've shown this
in multiple videos before.
It's negative b over 2a.
And I can't help myself, if
you look at the quadratic
formula, it comes straight
out of that.
The quadratic formula is
negative b over-- well, I'll
write it as negative b plus or
minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac.
All of that over 2a.
Or you could write it as
negative b over 2a plus or
minus the thing over 2a.
You normally just see it with
a big 2a in the denominator,
but you could split
it up like this.
And notice, this right here is
a formula, I just told you
it's a formula for the x-value
of the vertex.
Which makes complete sense
because the vertex is always
going to be along the line of
symmetry of our parabola.
And it is going to be equal
distant from each of the 0's.
So you get a 0 in the
plus direction.
This is the distance
right here.
This is one of the 0's in
the plus direction.
And then you subtract,
that's the other 0.
So it makes sense that negative
b over 2a is the
x-value of the line
of symmetry or the
x-value of the vertex.
Now with that said, let's
actually figure out what the
x-value of the vertex
is for this problem.
So we have x squared--
oh, sorry.
So negative b over 2a.
So this is equal to negative
5 because b is 5,
over 2 times 1.
Over 2.
So that's the x-value.
Let's figure out
where it sits.
Whether the y-value for
the vertex is below
or above the x-axis.
So the y-value, we'll just have
to substitute into this.
The y-value of the vertex is
going to be equal to negative
5/2 squared.
Plus 5 times negative 5/2.
And then finally, plus 7.
Let's see if this is
positive or not.
So negative 5/2 squared
is 25/4.
Minus 25/2, plus 7.
So we can add these.
Let's put everything over 4.
So this is equal to 25/4.
25/2 is the same
thing as 50/4.
Minus 50/4.
Plus 28/4.
This is equal to-- well,
we know our denominator
is going to be 4.
And you have 25 plus 28 is 53.
Minus 50 is 3.
So it equals positive 3/4.
So the y-value is positive.
It is above the x-axis.
So the parabola will look
something like this.
The parabola will look something
like this where the
y-value is 3/4 for the vertax.
The x-value we just saw
was negative 5/2.
And because the minimum point
of this upward opening
parabola is a positive number,
the minimum y-value is a
positive number, it's always
going to have values at that
level or above it.
So this is true.
If x is a real number,
then it is true.
It is always true.
It is always true that x squared
plus 5x plus 7 is
greater than 0.